[Musique]
c'est la fameuse semaine québécoise de
réduction des déchets qui débute
aujourd'hui et puis quand on parle de
déchets baisse inclut aussi les
appareils électroniques qui ne servent
plus ce que martin carli a surnommés les
sert plus à rien
il est avec nous d'ailleurs martin carli
vulgarisateur scientifique pour paroles
aussi mais retient de l'association pour
le recyclage des produits électroniques
du québec bonjour gamme en jeu ça tombe
bien que venus ce matin parce que je
regardais chez moi j'en ai pas mal à ces
cellulaires des ordinateurs pour un
reflux moins on hésite toujours à 100
départs s oui il y plaide excuses puis
la campagne de cette année a été axé
justement sur les excuses qu'on évoque
pour garder de ces appareils à la maison
on se bat peut-être qu'ils pourront
servir éventuellement je sais pas par
une certaine magie tout d'un coup il va
redevenir amende juste pas trop quoi
mais en réalité on s'en sert plus
vraiment jamais ça serait intéressant
d'aller les porter dans un point de
dépôt parce que ce faisant on va
réintroduire dans la chaîne de
production des ressources qui ont déjà
été extraites du sol et qui pourront
servir à produire d'autres produits que
ce soit des produits électroniques ou
d'autres produits et ça parce que quand
on les rapporte
il ya vraiment beaucoup de composantes
qui sont réutilisés par la suite oui
effectivement ça c'est le premier grand
bénéfice d'un programme de recyclage
comme ça on remet dans la chaîne de
production des ressources qui existent
déjà et le deuxième grand bienfait c'est
qu'on s'arrange pour intercepter des
ressources qu'on veut pas les voir dans
l'environnement du mercure du plomb par
exemple on veut pas non plus envoyé
notre notre recyclage de produits
électroniques dans des sites
d'enfouissement ou mon propre peut-être
contaminer l'environnement veut pas
faire ça et on veut s'en occuper nous
même de manière sécuritaire donc on veut
pas non plus envoyé ses déchets dans un
autre pays pour qu'ils s'en occupent à
notre place et et on veut aussi protéger
tous tous les gens impliqués dans le
processus et plusieurs objectifs à ce
programme de recyclage là et je pense
que ce sont tous ces objectifs le web
vous tenter aussi de réutiliser les
appareils si c'est possible ou les fois
bon décide que c'est plus bon pour nous
mais pour elle peut être utilisée les
claviers effectivement donc la première
étape
est-ce qu'il ya du réemploi possible
c'est la première ça c'est la première
étape donc lorsque les entreprises
certifiées qui ont été choisis par
l'arpp reçoivent les appareils mais on
regarde ce que c'est
réutilisable ou pas si c'est quand on va
réutiliser c'est normal c'est tout à
fait normal
et après ça c'est pas réutilisable on va
démonter trier les matériaux qui sont
dans un appareil on va déchanter
l'appareil pour pouvoir isoler les
différents matériaux et l'on va les
envoyer aux différents endroits pour
pour les recycler correct moi ce qui me
préoccupe martens et les données
personnelles que j'ai dans mon
ordinateur puis tout ce qu'il ya le mot
cv par exemple des documents s comme une
garantie cap a personne qui va partir
avec ça si on leur met en fait ça
c'était mon excuse à moi avant d'être
impliqué avec cet organisme là qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec nos disques durs qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec nos outils qui stocke
des données disques durs nos téléphones
cellulaires on a emmagasiné par exemple
des listes de niro téléphone c'est
précieux
[Musique]
oui exactement donc ce qui se passe il
ya des systèmes d'effacement de données
qui qui sont au début de la chaîne du
processus de recyclage
les disques durs par exemple vont être
même déchiqueté donc aucune
problématique particulière par rapport à
ça moi ce qui me rassure le plus bel
exemple que je me donnais lorsqu'on
parle de cette campagne là c'est le fait
que les banques elles mêmes font affaire
avec leur peau québec vont envoyer leur
parc informatique désuet à des
entreprises qui sont certifiés par
l'arpa québec pour s'en débarrasser je
me dis si les banques font détruire leur
disque dur comme ça au niveau de l'arc
québec mon vieux c'est vide 995
c'est bon de le dire tout à fait il ya
tellement de reportages aussi sur les
centres de tri qui débordent on sait pas
trop finalement le recyclage est ce que
vous sentez que ça n'est pas tout seul
et ferrandez par exemple qui dit qu'il
ne va pas recyclés et maintenant à
l'avenir ce que ça te décourage les gens
mais c'est sûr que lorsqu'on entend des
messages contradictoires ben l'on peut
décourager ça peut augmenter les excuses
qu'on peut avoir par rapport à un
processus comme ça faut savoir que le
recyclage des produits électroniques
c'est vraiment un système de recyclage
qui est indépendant qui qui est à part
entière et aussi ce qui est très
intéressant ce programme là c'est qu'une
traçabilité donc tout ce que vous allez
porter vont être suivies à la lettre de
l'arrivée dans le point de dépôt
jusqu'au moment où il a été complètement
recyclés par les recycleurs donc ça
c'est très important cette traçabilité
là les points de dépôt sont scellés on
ne peut pas les servir de dadar moi je
le prendrais stordis là je plonge la
main puis je le sors un peu toi même
dans les collectes publiques le toit
revêtent une sorte de chance dans les
bacs toile il console de jeux vidéo que
j'aimerais bien maintenant une
traçabilité c'est très important et donc
on est rassuré sur justement le fait que
le processus se fasse la bonne façon
mais c'est important de rappeler le
message qu'il ya 2300 points de dépôt
officiel à travers le pays mais au
québec et l'occupation rythme on peut
les apporter ou non sert plus à rien la
meilleure chose à faire c'est de
consulter le site web recyclées mais
électronique points c'est à nous en
avons non seulement la liste des points
de dépôt saleh a aussi à voir les dates
des collectes parce qu'il ya des
collègues de temps en temps et vous
allez aussi surtout avoir la liste des
150 produits qui sont admis dans ce
programme la passe il y en a beaucoup
informatique / on le sait l'homme et y
en a plein d'autres aussi aucun porte et
c'est surtout on n'est jamais un
appareil mis à la rue ni dans un bac de
recyclage à savoir pour se rendre au bon
endroit martin calais merci beaucoup
merci merci